justin bieber dodges a water bottle from
the crowd after he refuses to sing death
fascism
[Music]
the 23 year old popstar performed at the
summer burst festival in Stockholm
Sweden over the weekend where one fan in
the audience yelled for him to sing his
remix of Luis FONSI and daddy yankee hit
singles juice Buffy which just so
happens to be in Spanish someone in the
crowd didn't like Justin's answer and
hurled the water bottle at him Justin's
refusal to sing des besito was probably
a good choice in May the singer fumbled
through the song during a special
appearance at 1 Oak in New York ad
libbing random lyrics in place of the
Spanish word
[Music]
but get this response me and daddy
yankee told et it was actually Justin's
choice to record the track in Spanish
well that was awesome
yeah we're going to nobody was affecting
that right like he is singing in Spanish
and we had an English lyric for
everything and he's like no no no I'm
going to do this in Spanish he took the
time to enunciate everything and to do
it the right way so I think it's a big
win for Latin music and it's awesome to
have such a huge global star you know
collaborate with us
[Music]
you
[Music]